hi my name is bradley gila i am a young
filmmaker from australia and i'm
currently directing a film called the
ketchup onion when I was like a kid I'll
always remember seeing like a camera cuz
my dad used to videotape like like all
my um my baby videos I don't know it was
something that I always thought was
interesting you know those the phrase
are like a picture of paints a thousand
words I like to imagine that film does
that a thousand times more there nam
photography yeah that kind of sparked an
interest for film for me at a time when
I was six I was just watching movies
like constantly and the films that I
would watch them are so adventure films
so to catch a bunyip is basically a film
about this young girl mo who goes to the
Billabong everyday because she believes
that the Bunyip lives there and she
wants to capture it for its magic
because she believes that bunyips have
the power to regenerate life she wants
to get the magic because she wants to
help her sick mom Jess who suffers from
Parkinson's disease her older sister
Abbie clashes with Emma because she
doesn't believe in blankets and whatever
is saying is all nonsense since she
wants to have Emma share more
responsibility what made you want to
tell this story this um this film that
making is a personal story that I wanted
to convey for about three years now
because my mom had Parkinson's disease
and it had like a significant impact to
the way that I was growing up as a kid
when I graduated of out of high school
my mom passed away from her 12 year
battle with Parkinson's disease and
for about two years I was depressed
because I wasn't really sure where my
wife was going after that so I wanted to
make this story to convey to convey my
feelings on that experience as well as
sort of an outlet for me to get over
those feelings and also move on the
reason why I incorporated bunyips I that
was a film that I watched was a kid
called dot in the kangaroo that was a
film that I used to watch with my mom
and I want to turn this bad situation
into something more lighthearted so I
merely thought of that film and that
that film happens to feature like like a
bun yep so I my wanting to draw
inspiration from that memory in
particular and make a film where it
comes from a very bad place into a more
lighthearted and fun adventure film the
story is much so not about the Bunyip
but rather the family but yet the bunny
is all a part of this and is the link to
the family you don't see the Bunya per
se but I've ridden it in a way that it's
left for interpretation whether the
Bunyip exists or not and it's something
for the audience for themselves to
decide on this is the first film I'm
directing well first you're filming
directing I've done directing in the
past where it was no 100% sure what I
want or what I'm going for but with this
I have like this queer idea in terms of
every small detail from production
design
locations I feel pretty confident as a
director to do do my job well I've spent
so much time just thinking to myself all
the small details of how it's how the
scenes are gonna play out how the shots
are gonna look how everything had the
performances are gonna play out during
the scene and the I mean obviously
they're gonna be issues that are gonna
pop up while filming but I I think I
have enough preparation to be ready for
the shoot and because of that I think
that I think this will turn out to be
really good in terms of the production
of the film so far it's been pretty
challenging to say the least because I
wanted to have this film set in the
1970s come with that is that it's not a
lot of occasions that are still in the
19th still in that era so I was very
worked up about finding the right
location that worked I feel like I'm
finding I'm getting I'm finding places
that are perfect it's just that it's
taking a lot of time to find the right
place that fits within the film I would
also have like the right you know paint
textures and I think it's it's worth the
white so find all the right location the
rather than just shooting over like a
mate's place because it shows that
there's a lot of attention to detail
during the course of production it felt
like I was reliving those moments when
my mom passed away because the way that
I wrote it was such a vivid part of that
experience it was during those memories
where I felt alone during the course of
writing
developing the story finding locations
costing it felt like I was very much in
the moment of that pivotal day and when
I was when I pitched the film that same
night my my nan passed away who is my
mom's mom and it felt like yeah it's
reliving pretty much those days but it's
good in a way because I believe with
with that I think I'll be able to direct
my head of departments and my act is to
bring them with me in those days
I'm definitely sorting things through
and I have a really strong team behind
me who makes this film there aren't as
well it definitely helps me knowing that
that the death or to support me as well
as I said before this story is about
family rather than the adventure that
the protagonist is having so for me it
was important to find people that looked
relatively the same the youngest girl
able is brilliant Ava was the the second
girl we Edition for the protagonist role
of Emma I immediately told the producers
that she was she was the one and we
pretty much casted her straight after
that one of the characters in my film
Jess I wrote her to intentionally have
Parkinson's disease and this character
is very important to me because she is
based on my own mountain and I wanted to
get my feelings off my chest into this
one character that means a lot for this
story and for myself I wanted to find
someone who it was really good at
like body performances and someone who
didn't who's willing to study how
Parkinson's affects you mentally as well
as physically and we came across Mel and
she was very genuine and I felt like
that she was perfect the rest of the
cast was great as well to help sell the
idea that everyone is a family and I
believe that that the perfect
I believe that perfect this film this
film is sort of independently raised at
the moment out of my mother's have
inheritance because I believe that might
as well use what she gave me to help
make this to make the the help make her
film the end goal with this film like I
said before I kind of want this to be a
film that's viewed as like a
quintessential film for Parkinson's
disease where the patients can watch and
it's something that they can relate to
yeah I think the most important thing
about this film it always starts with
the story because that's pretty much the
blueprint of any film and if you don't
have a good blueprint then you don't
have a good film I made sure to make the
some the script as tight and as vivid as
possible so when someone reads that they
get a good sense on how everything is
going to play it and I made sure that
like I'll leave room for actors
interpretations so that they can have
they can get into their roles more and
it doesn't have to be the same dialogue
from the script but something that comes
from from themselves personally I feel
like I'm now in position to give anyone
advice because I'm still learning but um
make films that you personally want to
make
I don't think personally you have to
experience something to make a good film
if you're willing to put in time and
effort into research to a particular
idea then I think if you believe in that
film then it could be possible to make
it happen and make it a really good film
yeah sure I like to think so
but I haven't seen one I'm sure they're
out there
somewhat